[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday April 17
using less energy more wisely is good
for everybody it's good for the world
it's good for the economy and I want to
make the whole world proud of this state
because we can govern and I attended a
stovetop rally whether it's occasionally
boring bureaucrats folks waving signs
and playing blues music and dancing the
drum beats and then we walked home it's
a small town so it can pretty much walk
everywhere on the way home we saw
several methods of alternative
transportation including ourselves
walking this train training and this guy
riding his bike the rest of our
electricity free day was pretty easy but
it did get a little bit difficult around
dinnertime ah can you see me you see me
at all without the light on cuz that's
too bright there's my teeth there I am
we got some electronic equipment on but
only electronic equipment that has
batteries it's kind of hard to eat food
or cook food anyways without power so
I'm not sure what we're going to have
for dinner
maybe we should cook it over the candle
oK we've figured out some food options
Catherine has in front of her a piece of
bread some cottage cheese pickles and
olives I have in front of me a tortilla
with mozzarella cheese slices tofu
Turkey and honey mustard and we have
also got on the table chips and salsa
mint many of which need to be
refrigerated but none of which need to
be heated though it sure would be nice
to heat this tortilla thing up there are
handles and then Catherine and I read by
candlelight until we fell asleep which
was very early it's a lot easier to go
to sleep early if you don't have light
bulbs as there's nothing else to do I
have to say that doing that for one day
it's pretty hard doing it for more than
one day would be much harder you mean
one day you don't really have to take
shower you can go out to eat for lunch
you can have a really lame dinner and
not suffer too much but doing it for an
entire week I don't know how you're
gonna do that and that's four lightbulbs
it is really hard to not have lighting
candles are actually much more
inefficient than light bulbs per unit of
light they create much more carbon than
a light bulb powered by a coal power
plant little guys when they're burning
they put off carbon dioxide just like
any other fuel they also don't put off
very much light as I found out sitting
in my bed holding my book up to the
candle to try and read at 10 o'clock at
night I generally go to bed about 2:00
a.m. it was a very inviting experience
we spend 100% of every day surrounded by
electronic stuff it completely defines
our life every bit of electronic
equipment has that carbon footprint tied
to it that's an interesting world we
live in John but I think it is good to
try and understand what life would be
like without that stuff sometimes all in
all I don't think it would be better
which is why I spend a lot of time
trying to figure out how we can go
forward there's no way we can get out of
this mess without a lot of really good
ideas I think it's good that you haven't
decided to just offset your carbon with
some strange scheme you've got to figure
out what devices actually make your life
better so you don't have to use all the
other ones at the same time I know that
this week is going to be a huge pain in
the ass and I look forward to seeing you
dealing with that tomorrow